>> ♪ ♪
>> ONCE AGAIN THE MEDIA
ACCIDENTALLY PRESENTS A STARK
CONTRAST BETWEEN THEIR PHONEY
STORY TELLING AND REAL LIFE.
THEY LINKED THE JOKER TO WHITE
RAGE.
AS IF THEY HAD THESE PIECES
WRITTEN BEFORE BY THE SAME CNN
INTERN.
ONE PLAYED OUT FOR REAL ON THE
STREETS OF NEW YORK.
A MADMAN HEARDED 4 HOMELESS MEN
JUST BLOCKS FROM THE MAYOR'S
OFFICE.
HE HAD NOT SEEN THE YORK.
-- JOKER.
HE HAD 14 PIRACY.
HIS CRIME WAS THE RESULT OF A
BUREAUCRACY THAT WASHES ITS
HANDS FOR THE HOMELESS.
I KNOW THE JOKER SUFFERS FROM
MENTAL ILLNESS BUT THE
GOVERNMENT SLASHES HIS
TREATMENT.
THAT'S A MORE RELEVANT PLOT
POINT THAN RACE.
AMERICA'S GOVERNMENT IDEA OF
TREATMENT IS THE STREETS.
THE SATURDAY NIGHT MASSACRE
WON'T LEAD THE NEWS BECAUSE THE
HOMELESS ARE NOT THE PRETTIEST
VICTIMS AND THE PERP IS NOT A
MUSTACHE TWIRLING VILLIAN.
THE MOST DESPERATE ARE LEFT TO
SUFFER UNTIL THEY TURN ON
THEMSELVES.
IT'S NO STORY FROM D.C. COMICS.
BUT THE OTHER D.C.